- So, Australia is running an experiment
on what happens when you
don't have the equivalent
of the Communications Decency
Act Section 230 on the books.
In Australia, it appears that
the High Court has determined
the media companies are liable
for the content that any other user posts
to their website or Facebook page,
and this is something that a lot
of people think should be
adopted in the United States,
because they feel that tech
companies have too much power
and they're silencing
voices, though, to date,
they've been hamstrung by Section 230
and the First Amendment
to the U.S. Constitution.
Now, I am not an Australian lawyer,
take this with a grain of salt.
I'm doing my best to parse
what I can see coming out
of the Australian courts,
but at first blush,
this decision seems to be
the opposite of Section 230
and the media companies might
be liable for these comments,
so they will be running
a natural experiment
as to what actually happens
when the internet doesn't
have the equivalent
of the First Amendment or Section 230,
and I'm as interested as you
are in finding out what kind
of unintended consequences, if any,
come as a result of this finding.